thousands of runners will be taking over
the strip it's this weekend for the rock
and roll races kevin martin joining us
now from the strip kevin has a preview
of all the festivities hey there kevin
well hey brian after two year pause due
to covid rock and roll las vegas is back
in a big way over 30 thousand runners
are expected to participate from all
over the weird world excuse me in this
two-day event that will take place on
the strip and in downtown las vegas and
you can feel the excitement building
around the city
honestly it feels amazing to be here to
be standing here i can feel the energy
after a two-year hiatus due to covet
rock and roll las vegas is back this
weekend featuring a 5k saturday as well
as a 10k and half marathon on sunday
this town has missed this event we've
missed being here with over 30 thousand
participants expected to run over the
two-day event and not to mention
shutting down the strip putting on this
event is no easy task these things don't
happen overnight so there's a lot of
planning that takes place to host an
event like this and this is the first
time that they a property has hosted
this part of the rock and roll marathon
so it wasn't easy but we were able to
pull it off that image of the start line
is my favorite picture it says it all
when you have thirty thousand you've got
probably looking at four or five
thousand people at one time getting
ready to run that says vegas is back and
in true las vegas fashion this race is
next level vegas is our super bowl so
because of what we're able to do here
shutting down the boulevard at night
we've completely taken what would
normally be a wonderful race experience
and just elevated it the runners are
already envisioning crossing the finish
line after trekking 13.1 miles down one
of the most iconic roadways on the
planet and when you finish it you get
that meadow around you you feel that
excitement we did it
now the 5k will take place saturday at 5
p.m in downtown las vegas while the half
marathon and 10k will take place right
here on the strip on sunday start time
is 4 30 p.m reporting live on the strip
kevin martin live local now it's a great
energy it's almost electric really a fun
event several road closures tomorrow and
sunday along the race route again race
areas impacted included the strip in
downtown also some ramp closures on i-15
find maps of those closures at eight
newsnow dot com the runners are wild oh
yeah they're so excited there's only a
couple times a year we close the strip
right some of them are running with a
can of beer and they've been partying
and it's a whole thing
that's a whole culture